what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here because we don't want to
apologize that's the name of the episode the
original title I don't want to apologize and
then someone typed it on chat gbt on how to
shorten it and they called it no apologies
the AI is taking over Jack Reacher season two
get ready that's what it's gonna be about I
have a lot more thoughts than a typical intro
John how are you uh great I'm really excited
for more of your AI apologies guys leave a like
everyone leave a like leave a like do it reach
for that like button oh God also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get notified
when our reaction for episode 6 is up here on
the Chanel these thumbnails on Amazon are very
misleading also fully threatened watch launchers
We sync with your own copy of Reacher available
for our super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you all for joining just for the show alone
however we also cover several things over there
exclusively reaction highlights and watch along
is included John are you ready to apologize I'm
always ready for an apology Greg you ready for
an apology already two I'm ready I'm so sorry I
should have said I'm ready to apologize all times
foreign [Music] blockade has been credited
with hundreds of successful search and
seizures of Contraband including oh [__]
the only way to make Molly best death mean
something is by catching whoever killed
her we can't do that if we're shot dead by
crooked cops or rotting away in jail with
her murder pinned on and also taxidermy
the dog pull over this dog better not be
dead oh he's gonna murder that guy it's okay
enough of this pretty old they need
to save something oh they didn't
do anything to anybody doesn't deserve
this I told you to stay off my property
rung his Bell geez oh yeah there you go
there you go let's see how you like it
peace Property Owners always ready to go but never
around defeat his dog he's always in
the right around the backyard Corner
Richard break into that computer
there oh the 1989 Batmobile
[Music] oh man wow
illegal money is awesome my buck or something
I think that's a Bentley that's a Bentley
the cattle I told you to stay off my
property these are my cows [Music]
oh put that thingy from the second episode yeah
oh it's a flashback from the second
episode it all makes sense now
oh damn oh boy I can't be seen with a
[__] I have nothing if not a Pious man
look it's the war criminal trying to use that
one thing against him you're interrupting our
launch let me ask you something what kind of man
are you a stupid man a bitter man a white man you
knew I'd come after you when I saw what you did to
Roscoe you knew I'd see your truck right outside
a work truck whose beds never had anything in
it other than a keg I know what you don't know
what's that what it feels like when I hit you
because if you did you never would have picked
up that paint can now let me tell you something
about Roscoe Conklin she's a war criminal hello
with the cloth oh
yeah baby
don't even try drop it hey I never
liked you Dawson don't make me prove it
it's just the moment this man arrived at margraves
there's been nothing but violence and now he's
attacked my son that's it you get him out
of here last time I checked you are my boss
is a call away Junior and the boys are just
minding their own business when this guy can
even started tearing up the place thank you Earl
for being a good citizen of mongrave Detective
Roscoe take a Reacher outside why I
beat the [__] out of everyone in here
get it quick again in the barrel stupid
well I bet that because she cared about a Reacher
well I'm telling you man I feel like Roscoe's
gonna die are you kidding me no no I just got
the report mixed up with something else [__]
easy what's going on you just fired me whoa
let me talk to the man okay this is [__] is
he going back to jail Kleiner is impressive
charges because he doesn't want to go to court
a lawsuit lets me ask for discovery about KJ for
character impeachment [Laughter] yeah yeah
so it's down to Grace files I told you he
didn't leave anything behind but he left you
as Desert Eagle people thinking about suicide
normally give away their prized possessions
right before they take their lives not a full
year prior good call interesting I want to see
the box that came in just be careful with it
[Music]
secret box hahaha
oh Oh I thought it was a ring when we were
at the motel in Alabama you said gray used
to get his haircut once a week yeah what is
a man with hardly any hair needed weekly trim
he just likes to keep it tight you know
he wanted you to know he was proud of him
girl you're the best Barbershop man oh
Barbershop man it's totally dead Wowie
let me daisies oh who buys 116 cattle you buy a
lot 20 50 100 it's just I have a lot of animal
feed there's something inside those animals
when my uncle got up to around 120 head he
had to follow the state why so clanner stops
at 116. do not file he'd be subject to State
inspectors coming on his land and he has cows and
a herd that is not that big let it rest stretch
I swear to God you're not going to have to worry
about Kleiner because I will
cut your balls off myself you
a little sustenance thank sir you wouldn't happen
to have any food or Salad would you missed mostly
are you picky Bastard with mayo between two
slices of bread right right in front of it
thank you don't look a gift horse in the
mouth my guy why would you just ignore this
whole animal thing when Rachel's like right
about everything right we need direct proof
Lincoln counterfeit cash to cleaner and we
don't have it all the places I didn't do this
there are dying towns all over you just pick one
on a lottery throw a dart at a map the Old State
Route arterial systems cross right through
here shipping fake cash from here planners
trucks can avoid Federal interstates for most
of the trip literally staying off the radar
of cops with a much bigger presence on busier
highways he had a very well oiled and thought
out operation that's what I predicted exactly
man it was one step ahead of the show I'm just
such an idiot when it comes to these things the
case I've been going on for a year which means no
funny money coming into the U.S so there's a huge
backlog of counterfeit cash overseas making the
whole outfit vulnerable to being caught and that's
what's stored in the animals maybe someone wants
to buy something really dangerous it's really
expensive I think suitcase nuke but they don't
have the money to do it so they're printing their
own or they want to destabilize the US economy
bottom line I don't care why they
want to do it you and the FBI can
figure all that out after the people that
kill Joe were dead grading commit suicide
I'll talk to her you still gotta talk
to teal man you gotta talk to everybody
sir ma'am no apologies
damn it I messed that kid up you
better apologize I'm very sorry
for what happened I have no excuse for
my actions I hope you can forgive me
though I understand if you can't you're done
Richard does Joe and Jack don't have the same last
name I've been wondering that because even Joe
called him Reacher I apologize no look at my son
you can't even bring yourself say you're sorry
you're torturing that poor kid I'm sorry he
couldn't defend himself I'm sorry I'm sorry the
left side of his face doesn't look like the right
that's the day Jack Reacher hit the road that
is not what we rehearsed you want to save your
town avenge great good harness that bad people
should get what's coming to him no apologies
that's the name of the epoil got it she said
she wanted dinner at 10 but instead she had
it at six ten six is MP radio code for send
civilian police and she's taking a shot at me
for being a civilian now if she can't tell you
where she is how the hell are you gonna find her
won't be a problem oh yeah come on they got way
easier there's gonna be such a prevailing part
of season too she'll choose a decent discount
hotel some and you'd find near Midtown close to
public transportation you're a place to eat
that's reasonably priced and isn't a chain
restaurant why can't it be a chain restaurant who
would suspect a McDonald's I tracked you 10 years
together on special investigators I know what you
think figured I'd come to Midtown avoid tourists
find a serviceable hotel close to mass transit
near Artisan restaurant you found each other
the JW on your brother's punch list was an EPA
investigator named Jimmy Dupree Wilkes was gone
down in his home dad fed Ted fed determined it
was a random burglary gone bad murder weapon was
a small caliber nine millimeter subsonic porkless
don't use silencers most not color guns at all
also work there's two things he stole a life
the body was beaten like a pinata postmortem
I don't see that every day happens more often
than you think that's what they did to my brother
[Music] stepped in it now we're gonna
kill a whole lot of people aren't you
he's already started already started yeah I wish
I could tell you but the first two chapters of
book support cover the extent of the pollution
and the third chapter the one that deals with
the source is missing a missing Source it's
a guy like for the murders was ordered an
18-wheelers full of animal feed when he doesn't
need nearly that much do you see a connection
with what we're looking into not off the top
of my head hell a lot of animal feed though
right right because what I've been saying
this whole time why are you so big genetics
are you a giant
that looks painful instead of hitting
his head on something could something
have a hit his head till I never looked at
the injury that way candy oh now oh okay
there's a bullet in there
whoa kind of look like a diamond done
it the cane teals Kane teal would do
it himself I don't feel like he would but
I don't know I mean everyone's a suspect
there's an empty oil drum right there pig pen oil
drums cleaner than the river that's why we're here
why would you go fishing in there yeah what do you
hope to catch EPA came through here years ago talk
about how the geography makes the toxins settle
here chilling all the crawdads and catfish said he
was going to clean it up because no one could earn
on the water anymore you know what he did he died
he was killed yeah well so was this town do it for
this town Joe wasn't the first federal agent he
had killed he had woke's taken out too before his
polluting was uncovered just can't prove it got a
text from Little coin and see how he's ready to
meet game is on you come to clean out your desk
are we that is not what you're
supposed to do [Applause]
by now Tail's calling for your arrest and
once you're in custody though take you
out like they try to kill Richard when they had
him locked up oh no I gotta get you out of town
you can't show your face tomorrow grave now oh
hell no the show's not the same without her God
with me is a small time trigger pull that makes
you think this will suit him it's been a go-to
CI let's keep a c on the gravy train hey why
are we gonna do this man this case is closed
we got families you let it go this is not the
time for this chat this mess gotta thank you
it ain't worth our lives too if it was worth
my brother's life it's sure as hell with yours
so if you don't kill cops who does out of
town Talent a name you know what his mama
called him but he goes by the black
king no you find the Viking you found
your shooter now imma get me a lap dance
and no self-respecting stripper is going
to come to a table with two cops this
chick the pissed off Giant [Laughter]
oh yeah let's go Neely
yeah you're just shoving messages down
my throat some nice moves back there
better than the guy who taught him to me Jack
teacher hey we got there already got a call
from Stevenson saying till once a warrant out for
Roscoe's arrest can't trust Stevenson I told him
she was Furious about getting fired and that she
jumped out of my car the stoplight and took off
Roscoe I'm here who should do that Roscoe
I love you so much I go to the source after
hours see if I can get evidence that Nails
this thing down boy scouts kind of doing
a legal search that's for times besides
it's not like I'm killing someone [Music]
oh yeah you will I need you to promise me that
you're not going to take out teal without me
the time comes I'll hold him while you hit him I
love you so much Richard I said her name normally
I said in normal yeah yep tell me how I said it
you get to the precinct we'll go through the
Alias database the look of Vikings see what
pops up I think the cop driving is crooked
yeah I'm worried about the both of them
[Music]
I'm sorry
the woods I will open the door up stop and shoot
you real quick tell them now don't tell them that
yeah you put the wrong guy behind you
oh no
that's real bad my friend and I
are getting out of here I can try
and take you with us but if I do you're
going to jail and they'll kill you inside
so you could either die here and then
they'll come for your family and you
know what they'll do to them it's your call
wow oh my god oh yeah say your prayers match
whoa
Jack swimmer a lake like Jason Voorhees
you do not mess with the special investigators
you do not miss the special investigators
oh yeah
this is a size medium turned into more than
you bargained for when you agreed to help
do me a favor and walk away I love that detail
they actually put on a shirt it didn't fit
oh here we go thinly impossible okay
I think there is some type of alarm yeah
that's what I'm worried about [Music]
oh I had a feeling I should have
said it I hate when I don't see it
you better haul ass out of there yeah and God
though is like neck flaps for a second he said
he was gonna investigate I was like I bet he
climber's dead because I was thinking about Spivey
being dead yeah yeah and then I was like based on
the run time of this episode I'd imagine kleiners
probably did yeah these guys probably all have
leverage damn it got like climbers hate when I
don't say something pisses me off gotta say every
Theory pisses me off because everyone's gonna
remember five years from now when Greg made that
prediction on that YouTube video yeah he's like
I remember when Greg said it he called it every
subsequent season of Reacher people are gonna be
like wow Here Comes Greg ready to not call another
one re-watch this show without thinking about
when Greg called that moment ruined the whole
experience oh God I do it for you guys not for me
and my own Pride I do it for you all of you anyway
it's a service damn that was uh things are getting
real real things are getting real and personal
yeah I love that nuanced touch at the end there
with the cops yeah man because I was like ah it's
maybe just some crooked guy and then it wasn't
just like he's crooked he was threatened you know
even Jack Reacher seemed to like understand you
know for a second that is his family this guy's
family is at stake it's not guys balls yeah and
now we know that that's not an empty threat what
a what a motif what a threat to make sure some
people cooperate like that's the whoever is due
and pulling the strings here the Assassins that's
their signature calling card now what do they do
when when like a woman is the main target though
because if you don't have balls to cut off how do
they leverage you I don't know I don't know I love
that that that that that that has stuck around
like like they give you that idea with Hubble
in the first episode he's like they told me they
would do this and at first you're just like oh of
course they told you that because like you're just
gonna stay in like they're they're just talking
big and then you see it and now it's just this
like it's like an extra character that's just with
us the whole time and there hasn't been anything
like we're we're about to hit the sixth episode
and there's only been truly one seriously graphic
moment yeah right and it was just that with the
guy on the one like they needed to drive that home
like how real of a threat this is and all I needed
was that one like yeah you got the like the prison
fight which was cool and like some bone crunching
stuff um foreign but no nothing like what they
had what they had in the second episode with the
crime scene and you know like whenever they talk
about that happen they're just that just lays the
ground floor of yeah these threats are real and
they will do some messed up stuff and so I love
that because it's it's such a phrase of like I'll
cut your balls off or something like that you know
everything yeah but then the show of how they
do it and then they get like they crucify you
oh yeah you you list you know when like a
cop is threatened in that position like he's
he's been pushed to that point and you can
see that he wasn't really a bad guy yes cop
and he was even trying to stop them from
investigating earlier yeah right I love that
like his yeah because he plays it I thought the
actor played it well enough that it could just be
oh you know maybe he just isn't down for this
you know maybe he thinks this is risky but no
they've already gotten to him have we not met the
bigger Baddie yet that's how it feels and I mean
especially because we've had these figures like
Kleiner and teal and and all these like corporate
guys but aside from like the the you know Hitman
and the you know like the different little South
American guys who are running around you know
trying to jump reach her I feel like you know
there's it could be the Viking it could be
something else but I feel like there has to
be another more violent figure involved that like
would get their hands I feel like we haven't met
or you know been exposed properly to the person
who would get their hands dirty for this stuff
yeah because I feel like they've been trying to
set up like kleiner's son to be something more
see I keep feeling like yeah like
they they're doing that but he'll
see now I don't know because Kleiner senior
is dead maybe that will be some kind of twist
where it's like I never had a good relationship
with my dad I had him killed myself or something
like that but I don't know I'm torn between him
being an innocuous Red Herring versus him being
as suspicious as they may come out to be yeah
and the show does a really good job at hinting
at history with every character they do a really
really good job you have this thing with Neely
and Jack where it's one buddy from the Army who
actually stays in contact with and she doesn't
feel woke I know right all right guys isn't that
the way you want to say things about any woman
character you put them on a barometer culture of
are they woke or not woke you can't just accept
a character you can't just accept that people
have these views and might just demonstrate
Sometimes women have skills fighting skills this
didn't happen until people started using the word
investigative skills yeah yeah sometimes women
can also do things without it having to be in
a category called woke uh yeah I I like I like
her a lot and yeah they hand out you really get
the sense that you know she's probably a character
in previous books I I may be wrong about that but
she just reads that the way they introduced
her was like a Marvel character introduction
you know like I'm calling someone special
and then like fans of the book would be like
Punisher called micro all right yeah some some
Vibe like that that's sort of the impression I had
um and yeah like the way they talk allude to you
know being trained like the way they've helped
train each other and train together and there's
a kinship between them a Bond's stronger than
what anyone we've seen reach or half he cares
about her yeah actually he doesn't care about
people he cares about her we know Richard cares
those muscles can't cover up that heart blood to
that heart with him his his heart must beat like
a kettle drum yeah well I love this their Rapport
back and forth because they're so comfortable with
each other and like their friendship really plays
like even it's just like a small thing but even
the way they're like changing together and it's
not a thing like it almost feels weird to call
attention but the fact that they don't really
at all like shows how comfortable but how just
kind of you know at ease they are with each other
without it having to be any kind of other thing
than that yeah you know and uh I mean I don't
anticipate anything too terrible happening to her
but with her going off on her own I'm a little
worried it's like she's a season two character
I hope so yeah I mean I feel like she could
maybe later on in like a season three or four be
called into greater apparel but I feel like yeah
this will this will set up the connective tissue
because we're probably not gonna see Mark uh
you know uh Roscoe and Finley I don't deep dive
into the comments because I'm constantly worried
about getting spoiled yes um you guys have
been really good about not mentioning if Alan
Richardson is American or dad I still don't know I
still have no idea either I'm waiting to find out
um yeah so I I have no idea who will actually
die or if they all make it out of this season
alive or anything like that or if Neely will be a
character who prevails however this sense that I
get from the comments is that if I'm not mistaken
this is based off of the 12th book Jesus so many
books it's like one of those airport novels right
like there's like a billion of these yeah like
put in a good way I guess well I've heard these
supporting characters are better flesh out here
than they usually are the books oh cool um oh
that's nice I I really like maybe read a comment
or two that said that so I I don't know what the
actual General consensus is really going off of
like one or two opinions I read yeah uh but if
I'm not mistaken it's pretty faithful to the book
uh it certainly seems to please many more book
fans than the films did yeah yeah uh well it's
primarily investigative where is it Jack Retros
like get to an action scene the movie yeah I want
to see an action scene yeah whereas here I'm
like action's cool and all but like I'm just
so like I just love watching them figure this out
yeah yeah and then it's cool how this is like us
it starts off like a small town crime that is
escalating escalatingly getting bigger in your
uncovering corruption and then the corruption
becomes more personal to the characters pasts
yeah like how they did that with Roscoe like
I don't know this gray guy and I don't really
care that he died but I care that Roscoe cares
and is heartbroken by it isn't that her daddy
yeah maybe I could be I could be wrong about
that you see their biological dad I thought
her dad was a cop or something like that I don't
know I'd have to go back and look for the detail
wouldn't she say they killed my dad at any
point probably not they killed gray yeah
that makes more sense I know they still call
it wrong about that his brother called him
yeah and I'm like is is Joe like your
adoptive brother or something or you
you look the same so like do you call Joe
Reacher seems like you just call him Joe
yeah and then Jack's even said at one point to
um Roscoe like Mary Beth is her name Mary Beth
Molly Beth Molly Beth died she cared about one
reach that whole thing about she cared about one
reach her and she died yeah so Joe has to be
the other original yeah yeah I mean I that's
how I'm that's how I've always assumed that they
are biologically both reachers and not just like
I consider him a reason look and apparently they
look exactly the same yeah they sound similar and
and even the cast of The the brothers and the
young versions of them to look pretty similar yeah
so they have to be yeah I know it gets confusing
it's weird town where they just don't call either
but yeah no either way though even without the
full context of who gray is to I I agree yeah like
who he is to Roscoe like just the way that she
plays that and I love like her and Jasper going
over the I do think it's a little suspicious The
Jasper didn't like enhanced this wound the first
version on it that's right he's been pulling this
straight he's the least uh suspecting character
but but I loved her just little like the little
nuances of her performance having to power through
this really kind of traumatic reliving of this
event but also getting to the bottom of the clues
I guess I could see it from a Jasper standpoint
like this town doesn't experience murder
even though they have us even though
they have the best goddamn Cups
he's too friendly and Roscoe highly
over qualified guys yeah seriously
um Roscoe trained by the FBI at all um but the
town hasn't experienced murder so I could see
how if they didn't even think to look for it
they wouldn't have and yeah and if it really
looks like the particular situation that it
was supposed to look like then yeah you would
just kind of go okay he probably hit his head
on the chair Etc yeah um but yeah I mean it's
it's cool it's cool there's some so it's a bit of
swashbuckling vibe to it at times too like it it
pushes past uh just investigative mystery into
treasure hunt yeah this is this show has a really
interesting tone for what kind of show it is
because I've seen various you know uh crime
investigation procedural mini series very popular
genre lots of different cultures have them you
know especially in prevalence now and this one has
a certain element of of fun despite like the Grim
nature of so many of the circumstances and the
sordid you know spiral of the actual history like
but it's still like it's a swashbuckling I think
does kind of Broach on it because it is it does
have like a very very grounded sort of Adventure
kind of quality and you're like going all through
like they depict these areas of you know the
country in a very Vivid and tangible way to so
yeah like even though it doesn't feel like you're
like swamped territory like true to detective I've
only seen the first season But True Detective felt
like you know uh an icky Noir just Southern Gothic
detective show like and I loved I love that season
that was great um that really had that Flair we're
here I wouldn't remiss someone for thinking it's
PG-13 until suddenly you're like oh there's a lot
of hard efforts of nudity oh surprising violence
but the rest of the show looks like it can be like
a PG-13 show until some like R-rated [__] pops
up you're like oh yeah is there an R-rated show
well and I like that they use those pulpy things
in a way that doesn't come across with an R-rated
attitude it's like they go into a strip club and
there isn't nudity in that scene but it doesn't
feel like there's no requisite like we're in a
strip club kind of shot it's just like oh yeah
there's some nudity in the background but whatever
that's not the point you know it's kind of yeah
and even in the those moments like when they
change together like it is just kind of casual and
you're like yeah you know like this doesn't feel
mature explicit or exploitative in any way yeah
yeah yeah it's good stuff yeah this is good
stuff and there's a lot of great unspoken
qualities between Roscoe and Reacher as
well I love the actress plays Roscoe she
is terrific man I don't know if I've ever
seen her before but I hope to see her again
I hope she gets so many roles I get sick of her
and root for her downfall I can't wait to see
you again all right guys well thank you so much
for being here please be sure to go ahead leave
a like subscribe do all those things and last
but not least let's end this with shouting out
some patrons Ryan Smith caught you right at the
end of the month there welcome Kevin Meek you're
amazing Adrian Tims you're tremendous Ryan Baines
I love you Jeffrey Robinson just want to give you
a back rub real nagas cuddle with me Lex you're
the bestestist Marco fan 101 fart on my face
let's kick it into Heather gear Ian Simon stop
watching me when I shower Songhai Glover can you
make me some pancakes Jacob Neptune those photos
were supposed to be in private I bow down to you
Kayla the king Alan Ling we can't discuss legal
issues on the YouTubes Logan Burton do you want
to go the promise me yes or no Kiara he's my son
too aircon's 39 King of the prime numbers KUSI
KUSI you can't say things like that in front of
my friends Nick hex whoa this is a kid's show all
right this is for children this is John January if
you want to bring another person into the bedroom
you gotta run it by me first one Longoria that is
not a toy Gail Ferguson did I say you could have
some of my fries Cliff Rodriguez give me back my
family Master T oh sorry I didn't know you were
doing that anymore the door without knocking goat
Nation I'm not mad I'm just disappointed florenza
Baxter maybe put a towel on when you come out of
the shower huh differently saying come in from
the rain and get warm or go tonsil what are you
we're just staring at like staring at me like that
Lauren American Horse you're a gosh darn American
hero and Tim and I respect you simply faded open a
window for Christ's sakes some nebulist Jester
94. so Justin Martin you have time to put out
a tweet but not text me back is that it Rosie
Beatty you never came to one of my soccer games
not one Colin I got you on camera you're the
one who backed into my car Philip J Smith Jr
you've just been served sorry Jen Smith I do not
want to go to church with you Melanie LeBlanc I
found five friends and they found five friends
so so we'll join your network marketing company
it's good thank you guys for being here always
personalized customized messages tailored to
each of your personality every one of you and our
one-on-one interactions have we all had definitely
this is based on mountains of interaction love
y'all see you soon [Applause] foreign [Music]